[Music]
[Applause]
I'm here with Roberto viola of the
European Commission here in Amsterdam
Roberto thank you for talking to us
today
how do you think we're doing with ftth
in Europe compared to say other parts of
the world well we are in the race there
are scenes which are going well as well
we will publish our fresh data in June
but already from published data prison
for OECD we can have an idea where we
stand we are doing very well compared to
United States we'll be tired in terms of
fiber deployment we are not doing not so
well compared to Korea or Japan where we
have some work to do to catch up so we
are standing in the middle nicely in the
middle or not so nicely well that's
better than being behind isn't it
because obviously fiber is so critical
to all these other exciting things 5g
IOT artificial intelligence absolutely
no fiber no party I mean that's very
clear all this kind of brave new world
which is very important to curious
better safer car or whatever needs
connectivity connectivity is not just
the little antennas it's also the fiber
connecting it so without fiber we will
not go very far what do you think are
the next sort of challenges that we're
gonna face in Europe as we move to this
5g Society well there are two or three
big challenges the first one is for sure
be sure we have the technology to go
ahead so Europe must possess the basic
ingredients in terms of a technology
leadership in order to deploy those
networks
the second element which is very
important for everybody the business the
citizens security of those networks
those networks have to be secure the
more the society becomes digital the
modern society of course is opposed to
digital security issues which we call
cyber security so that's very important
the third point is I'm afraid money
investments investments investment these
are very necessary ok thank you very
much for talking to us it's a pleasure
thank you very much
so an interesting perspective there we
need fiber to join the 5g party
[Music]
[Applause]